I feel like I'm just using and abusing
technology just to make a business.
So, like with software,
think about like software,
you can make copies of it
and it doesn't cost you anything.
Stephen Blum, thank you
for joining me on 20 Minute Leaders.
It's been almost seven years
since we worked together last through
the Hacking Generation Y company
that I ran.
How are you?
So good.
Amazing.
That was the same response
you gave me seven years ago.
So, I'm glad that
I feel so much has changed
and then you're being consistent.
So, I just love that.
Stephen, you're the
chief technology officer of PubNub.
I am incredibly excited to learn more
about what you guys are doing
and diving into some of the things
that really make you excited about
the technology your developing.
But before that, I always love starting
with the journey of the entrepreneur
and the journey of the leader.
Because you have a phenomenal journey.
You've worked at quite a few companies
as lead as senior developer
and architecture.
So, tell me a little bit about
what you're passionate about
and take me all the way back
to your college days.
How do you get excited about technology
to the point where you are now?
Oh wow.
Yeah. It's a lot, yeah.
Really, it's all about
that means to an end.
So, technology,
sure, it's great.
And it can get you
to where you want to go.
From what gets me excited,
what really excites me
is that business model.
Right.
I'm really attracted that business model.
Yeah, attract that repeatable opinion.
You don't hear that so much
from chief technology officers, right?
Yeah.
That's actually a good point.
And I feel like I'm,
I'm just using and abusing technology
just to make a business.
So, like with software,
think about like software,
you can make copies of it
and it doesn't cost you anything.
I like that idea.
That means production costs
are pretty dang low.
So, how can we make that a business
and then how can we make
that easily consumable?
If you just press a button
and you magically gets a PubNub,
for example,
that's like the best possible business.
Because it's like money in,
easy, no problem.
And it takes a little bit more than that
with a company, like PubNub,
there's of course, that freemium model,
right?
So, it's like gives you the taste,
make sure that
it's what you're looking for
and gives you that aha moment.
Oh wait a second,
I didn't know that's something
that could be done?
Like that's what one
of my challenges is
trying to educate the market, saying,
this is something that you can do.
And especially now
with a lot of the work from home,
we've seen a massive increase
in our graph of traffic gaps.
Since you started on PubNub,
what is PubNub?
What service are you providing
and what is that aha moment
that you're referring to
that people already in the
freemium model are getting?
Yeah.
So, we're a communications platform
that allows multiplayer gaming,
or delivery
or peloton bike experiences
where you shared in a classroom.
And there's just so many,
like we have delivery services that uses,
it tracks the car on the map
as it's going by, like,
How close is my Chipotle order?
I'm hungry.
I want it, I need it now.
So, that's the kinds of things
that we take care of.
And we do it really, we're better
than everyone else doing it.
And we've got,
we're actually the world record holders
in the largest online events.
Yes.
What does that mean?
Tell me about these
world record holder holdings.
For the largest number of concurrent
audience members in history,
in human history,
we hold four sporting events
in a subsidiary of Disney.
We powered their televised event
and millions,
tens of millions of viewers
were all connected
with the shared experience
powered through our network.
It's sort of like
a nice little badge of honor
that we have,
that we've achieved.
Stephen, You're sitting either
at home if it's covid,
or in your office
if it's the regular life.
And in real time,
you have tens of millions of people
that are getting their data,
getting their experience
through PubNub.
And it's a technology
that you're responsible for.
You are the leader of it.
You're holding the technology stack.
Right?
Is that scary?
Is that fun?
Oh, it's exciting.
There's just so much.
But it's also a little,
like you're saying, scary.
Yeah, because we actually
we power airports
in the fueling of planes
and we make phones ring
and really important messages
that go through the system
and we can't lose them.
Like if we lose them,
some catastrophe is awaiting.
And we have to keep innovating.
We have to keep software moving.
So, we have to build a system
that is able to be updated
while not dropping a single message.
That's hard.
That's scary.
That's challenging.
And that's what we're doing
and that's what we're really good at.
You mentioned the term,
"educating the market" before.
Actually, a lot of the things
that you've been referring to
in this talk so far,
I feel like I think that I've been
learning through all these different
entrepreneurial courses at Stanford
or venture capital courses
or entrepreneurial courses
and Andreessen Horowitz articles,
and you've condensed that
into your PubNub journey,
which I think is just inspiring.
What is educating the market to you
and how did you need to educate
the markets to get PubNub
to where it is today?
So, it's the same challenge
with every company.
It doesn't really matter if you have
a very specific product or sort of
a horizontal communications network
like we have,
the challenge is finding a way
to communicate with a specific industry
in this case.
So, how I was describing
the car in the map
that's going through,
you can see how close
your Chipotle order is.
You need to have those stories.
You need to relay them
in a digital fashion
in a way that's consumable
for your audience,
your target audience.
Right.
That's like the hardest part.
And it also feels
scary to do that
because now you're,
you're like siloing your market.
And it's like,
but we're only going to capture
this level of revenue.
And then it's like,
what about all this other
sea of revenue over here?
You're leaving it on the table?
Actually, no, you're not,
because you're going to laser focus
and you're going to nail that target.
You're going to get those customers
to that aha moment.
You're going to be able to bring in
more qualified leads and then
you can take that pattern.
And this is a cool part,
this is the part I love, I love this,
you can repeat it,
you can repeat that pattern and go after
all the rest of those industries
and all those markets and win
at a much better rate.
And that's critical.
You have to do that verticalization.
So, from what I understand,
a lot of the majority of people fail
at that laser focus part, right?
So, they may have a good product,
they have a good idea,
they have a good sense of the market,
but they fail to have that laser focus.
And I'm thinking back to
first run article about superhuman,
where they talk about how they,
how they nailed down
on their target market
and really were laser focused.
What was that experience like for you?
How do you become laser focused
on a specific submarket of the
submarket?
It's trial and error,
but also, if there's a bigger hurdle,
it's ourselves.
It's ourselves.
Because convincing ourselves to do it,
is the biggest challenge.
And we're a big team, right?
And a lot of folks are responsible
for getting those key metrics successful.
Right?
We have targets and goals
and we have to hit those.
And then if you just focus
on one particular area,
it's worrisome.
So, trying to get us all
on the same page to do that,
that's been the number one challenge.
It's the hardest part.
I love it.
Stephen, take me back 10 years.
You're starting out PubNub,
what was it like?
Tell me the founding story of PubNub.
So, I've always been entrepreneurial.
My family, my grandfather,
they owned a local business
in the city and they sold
pipe fittings and in other types
of utility systems.
I don't know if that inspired me
or ingrained me into just being,
oh, this is the way it needs to be.
We just have a business
and you go for it.
And finding like, an approach,
I always had that a desire.
So PubNub, just like,
oh, this is a new way,
here's a problem.
This phone over here,
like I want this phone
to talk to that thing over there.
And I want it to be as easy as possible.
How can I make that possible?
How can I do that?
Well, I didn't know much
about networking.
I didn't know much about,
it was like,
how can I make that easy?
Okay, I need to learn about this.
I need to learn about Linux Kernel APIs.
I need to learn about networking,
what is an Ethernet frame,
what's a TCP tuple,
can we do UDP,
what is that,
what is even that, right?
So, I had to figure all that stuff out.
I didn't know
but I wanted it to be the best.
I wanted it to have, like
all these technologies out there
that allowed you to do
communication had limitations.
Right.
Like the AT&T network,
they have so much hardware
because the software has limited
and like, I don't want that limit.
When I make phone ring
across the world,
I don't want it to wait three seconds
because it has to go
through all these switching boards.
I want it to do as soon as you press
your finger on the phone,
the call button,
I want it to ring on the other side.
Like that's what my goal was.
So, like having that objective
for high quality and efficient,
and then being able to sell it as well
without having any overhead,
that was the goal.
Like creating a business
that could do that
and get people really excited.
And then I could take it
and then show people
how cool it was
on every single possible use case.
That was the vision.
That was the driver.
So, I'm going back to the beginning.
You're saying the technology for you
as the chief technology officer
is a means to an end.
You're really excited about the impact
that you're able to make,
whether it's connecting tens of millions
of people and a single point in time
or over the span of ten years,
really educating the market
and becoming a market leader
in this multiplayer communication.
So, back then, when you're talking about,
figuring out TCP, UDP, Ethernet frames,
I mean, that's complicated stuff.
That's not the stuff
that the average person would just,
you know, on their Friday night
sift through Wikipedia
and research papers and learn about.
So, there has to be a deep
technological curiosity beyond
just the means to an end, right?
You would think?
Maybe.
So, like, would I do this for fun
just for the hack of it, right?
Like, that would be
kind of like the question.
Maybe.
I mean, I did some game development
back in the day and I thought
that was pretty cool, right,
getting into video games.
You're breaking the whole conception
of what I think
of a chief technology officer.
Stephen, this is very difficult for me.
Yeah.
I mean, I think,
no matter what your like approaches
and your stance on technology
and in your field as well,
I think it comes down to
what's driving you,
what's pushing you forward,
what's going to make sure
that you're succeeding
and you're always at the forefront.
It happens that technology
has to be there
in order for you to accomplish it.
If it was wizardry and magic,
I would probably,
I'd probably be doing that.
But this is as close as we get
to get technology.
So, Andreessen wrote the famous piece,
Software is eating the World.
You're evidently a key figure
in proving that
software is eating the world.
I love the analogy that you made to AT&Ts
hardware solution versus
a software solution.
Obviously Andreessen,
that's what he touches on,
the type that you can scale
at practically no cost
and get exponential increase in usage
for a relatively linear increase in cost.
I mean, that's the name of the game.
But it must not be that smooth
of a journey over 10 years.
It can't all be butterflies and muscles.
Right?
So, talk to me some of the hurdles
that you pass through
and how you overcame them?
Well, we have our software,
and we are human we make mistakes,
but we're really good at
realizing those mistakes.
And that's probably like
the best part of humanity is like,
I would say,
that's our strongest asset.
Right?
It's being able to recognize mistakes
and fixing them.
And we're not infallible.
We've made mistakes.
Some of our client SDKs
are connectors to our network
were running on AT&T phones.
And there was an upgrade that they made
which caused some sort of
incompatibility thing, and the device
connect and disconnect
over and over and over.
And we had to create new
cipher keys every single connection,
because we want to make sure
the connection is secure.
And then it cost,
and it was a slow rollout
and they didn't upgrade,
and eventually all the phones,
all the AT&T phones in America
were doing this.
They were doing connect, disconnect
over and over.
And we're like, "What's going on?"
We didn't have any logging
at layer five and we didn't know,
we just saw that
the CPU's are going through the roof.
"What's going on? What's going on?"
It turned out that we had
a faulty reconnect logic
inside of our SDK,
for the particular SDK
that AT&T was using on their phones.
And in order to solve that,
we to get all AT&T's IP block space
that they owned for the cell network
and then route them
to a specific destination.
So, that way we can get
the rest of the traffic healthy.
So, that happened this year,
that was this year.
Yeah.
And it was very tragic
and it was very heartbreaking.
And we did harm
some of our customer relationships
but we were able to figure out
what the problem was and we solved it.
And in the future,
if we run into this again,
we have the tools ready.
Right.
I love going back to what you said,
that as humanity, we're really good
as identifying the mistakes
we're making and hopefully solving them.
I don't think that, you know,
all of humanity is good at doing that.
I can think of a few examples
who we're not necessarily good
at doing that.
But I love the fact
that you are taking the lessons
and being very direct about it,
being very intentional about the lessons
that you've learned there.
Owning that mistake
and improving upon it.
And I think that's the responsibility
of being a leader and a market leader
and something as crucial
as multiplayer communication.
What were some of the most
enjoyable moments of this 10 year journey
as an entrepreneur?
That's working with the customers,
that's still is today.
Being able to see them like,
wow, is it really that easy? Yeah.
If I could make it easier,
I would.
And I am working on that right now,
making it easier, faster,
better, stronger.
We're not done yet.
Like some of our biggest customers
are multiplayer games for mobile phones.
They're huge and they have
the largest player base
and the most loyal player bases around.
And so,
we need to make sure they're happy
because we want to keep their revenues
growing as well.
They are our customers revenue
and just being able to provide that,
and say this is us,
we can do that for you
is very satisfying.
It's very satisfying.
Right.
Are there some lessons that you learned
as a technology leader in the company?
Because you're were both,
obviously, you're leading people,
but you're also leading technology,
and sometimes it feels that there's this
like, weird intermixing between
the different roles of being the CEO,
the CTO, especially in
record technology companies,
how do you look at your role
as a CTO in terms of leadership?
By example, I would say probably.
I mean, I kind of like
think of it from that.
I mean, if you're kind of going down,
because there's different flavors of CTOs
if you ask.
And this is actually
a common questions like,
"What do you do as CTO?"
Those kinds of things.
Like, what are you asking really?
Like, what are you trying to get at?
Usually these are
other technology folks
who are asking me this question
that are either in that role
or about to go in that role.
And it's very different.
Some are our VPs of engineering
and they operate the team
and sort of manage managers
and sort of help structure that out
and create like
trajectories and career paths.
Right?
There's that kind.
There's also innovators, right?
So, at a larger companies,
you've got these principal engineers
or CTOs and they look for the frontier.
They're like,
what's new,
what's amazing,
what can we do to our company
to make it more secure,
make it billion dollars richer
with modern technologies,
how can we inject those techs into it.
And so, for me, though,
I'm an entrepreneur,
like I said, a little different.
So, I focus on what can we do,
what metrics can we monitor
over the years
and for our teams to be able
to be more successful.
Right?
And to know that they're successful
even before they get like a review.
The annual review type situation.
How do we do that?
How do we make the business scale?
How do we solve training?
Right.
Because for us, though, it's really hard
because the language is different.
Yeah.
Every single customer
they come to us so, like,
we need real time geography map updates.
And now you've got
a wholly different than
multiplayer connectivity.
And I need to make sure that
we have these technologies
and we can filter these
and we have this number,
it's just a different
conversation each time.
So, it's hard.
So, that's the kind of things
that we solve.
I love that.
Stephen, I wish we could talk on
for another hour about this.
It's just so fascinating.
But unfortunately,
for some weird reason,
I called the show
20 minute leaders instead of
hour minute leaders.
So, thank you for being so generous
with your time.
I love to end with my favorite question,
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself.
Wait, that's like,
that's a really hard one to do.
You should have prepared me
for that one.
Maybe you did
and I didn't read the email.
I apologize for that.
But it is my favorite question
I'm not holding you accountable
for those three words.
Off the top of your mind,
what words come to you when you think of
what is the type of leader you are?
How would your co-founder
think of Stephen Blum?
Realization and overly excited.
I'm holding back.
I'm holding back right now.
I love that.
Stephen, thank you so much.
This is wonderful, really inspiring.
And I love following your journey.
Thank you for being a great supporter
seven years ago of my projects.
I'm very, very thankful for that.
And stay safe and stay healthy
throughout this pandemic.
Yeah, it's been great, thank you.
Thank you for the time.
And same to you.
Thank you very much.